in my last video I introduced to jQuery
in this video I'm going to talk a little
more about jQuery events so here's a
basic event so I'm going to select a
paragraph tag and then I'm going to
attach a click event so when any
paragraph is clicked this function right
here is run and in the console it's just
gonna say you click the paragraph now in
my last video I told you that your code
should usually be in a document dot
ready function to make sure the document
is fully loaded before the other code is
run while it is still used document dot
ready is now deprecated and there's a
more concise way to do the same thing
I'm going to put this whole thing in
another function we're gonna just put a
dollar sign and then we're going to put
this in a function here now instead of
document that ready it's just dollar
sign and then the function so I'm going
to take this here and put it right in
here there we go let's try this out
okay now when I click this paragraph you
click the paragraph you click the
paragraph you click the paragraph and if
I had multiple paragraphs every
paragraph would have that same click
event so in jQuery most Dom events have
an equivalent jQuery method here are
some more common ones we have double
click mouse enter mouse leave Mouse down
mouse up and hover so let me show you
some examples up here so if I just put
mouse leave here okay now when I click
the paragraph nothing happens but if I
make my mouse leave the paragraph it's
gonna say you click the paragraph it
really should say you left the paragraph
so double click Mouse enter Mouse leave
Mouse down mouse up these are pretty
self-explanatory
now the hover method takes two functions
and is a combination of the mouse enter
and mouse leave methods so so the first
function is executed when the mouse
enters the HTML element and the second
function is executed when the mouse
leaves the element so let me show you an
example of that okay so there's two
functions or just separated with a comma
here's the first function comma and then
we have the second function here so if I
run that
when I enter the paragraph you entered
when I leave the pier if you left I also
want to show you some common form events
so we have focus blur and change so if I
add an input field here okay so now I'm
selecting the input field that I added
up above and we're gonna do the focus
event so in the focus event that just
means when it gets focused so if I click
into this input field it's gonna say you
did something down the console and blur
is when you leave the input field and if
you do change that's just if the text in
the input field changes so if I put
hello here it says you did something and
if I say bye and then it says you did
something again because the text change
from hello to bye I'd hit tab to exit
the field before it recognized that the
text had changed
now all of the events I have showed you
so far are actually just shorthand for
the on method let me show you what I
mean so if we go back to the original um
click method on the paragraph here so we
we have this click event this could be
written differently instead of click
we're gonna put on here
now we're gonna pass in the word click
and then we solve the function so now
it's paragraph on click so when you
click the paragraph you know we're gonna
run this function and that's gonna act
just the same way so if I click this
paragraph you click the paragraph when
you use the on method you can do some
additional things for instance it is
easy to add multiple events so after
click here I'm going to put mouse enter
now you can put any number of events
here as long as they are separated by
the space character so I'm going to run
that now when I enter the paragraph it's
gonna say you click the paragraph and
when I click a paragraph it's gonna say
you click the paragraph so this will
bind the same action to multiple events
you can also use the on method to bind
actions you can pass an object into on
with one or more key value pairs with
the key being the event name and the
value being the function to handle the
event so here's the example of this
inside the on method we have this object
here and inside the object there are two
key value pairs so key is click the
value is the function we're going to run
key is mouse over the values the
function we're going to run here so
let's run that and see what happens
when the mouse goes over it says hovered
when I click it says clicked and you can
also remove an event listener with the
off method so let me put in this we're
gonna select a pee tag dot off click
we're gonna turn the click method off
the click event handler off so if I go
over the paragraph it's gonna say
hovered if I click the paragraph
nothing's happening I'm clicking but
nothing's appearing in the console
because we turned off the click Handler
and there's one final thing I want to
show you which is that you can set up an
event to run only once with the one
method you can change the on to one the
us on now it's 1 it's just gonna run
once so before it would show hovered
even everytime I went over it so you'll
go over at once
go off it go over it again and it's not
showing hovered again even though I'm
moving my mouse on and off of it it only
runs one time if you use the one method
okay that's jQuery events thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good